a book graphic flips to various video
clips black and white footage of a
bookshelf
a black male enters from an aisle to the
right flip the color footage of a young
white woman walking up an aisle of books
she grabs for a book on the bookshelf
flipped the black and white footage of
an older white woman sifting through a
card catalog
flipped to color footage a young asian
woman reading a book to young children
flipped the black and white footage of a
young white man sitting pulling a book
from a bookshelf
flipped the color footage of a white man
sitting scanning pages of a book flip
the black and white footage of a black
woman sitting at an information desk
a white band approaches with a book
flipped to color footage a young white
man and two young boys look at images on
a laptop
flip the vintage color footage of an
older white man pushing books on a card
flip the black and white footage of two
black men walking across two parallel
balconies in front of rows of books
one balcony above the other
[Music]
flipped a white woman with glasses
looking over information flip the
vintage color footage of a white woman
handing several books to a white man in
a suit
flip the title slide with a bookshelf of
blue colored books welcome to your
library
nlm national library week serving
scientists and society